how you doing people i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message
today's april 6 2022 and whether you're
a member of the lgbtqi
plus lmnop community or you're super
straight we welcome you here on the big
show we are live streaming of course on
rumble on blaze tv and on youtube
and there's a lot cooking
in the world before i do anything else
though i feel that i have to show you
something that arrived
in the mail to my house
yesterday because there's been a lot of
talk
a lot of yammering about what's going on
here in florida they're coming for the
gays desantis is hunting them down they
don't like them
it's bad run gays run
and then i went to the mailbox yesterday
as i do
and i opened up the mail and there was a
package
and it had two of these in it
these are
this is a onesie for a baby when we got
two of them as you know we have two
babies on the way
and they came from the governor himself
so if ron desantis hates gay people
hates gay families and the rest of it
he's got a really
really strange way of doing it i mean
look at that that's pretty cute come on
future freedom voter like i believe in
freedom of choice and all that stuff my
kids who will never be voting democrat
if they want to remain part of this
family that's how we're going to do it
anyway i thought that was worth showing
because the whole thing is just
so stupid we're actually not going to be
focusing that much on that today because
there's a lot going on that cold open
that we just showed you i mean it's
fairly obvious that old doddering
confused joe biden is not in charge and
there might be some other guy perhaps
who was once a two-term president not
too long ago that actually
is in charge so we're gonna dive into
all of that before i get to it though
ladies and gentlemen in six days don't
burn this country comes out you can
still order your copy now
and get it on april 12th on publication
datedaverruben.combook
they're selling like hotcakes
what is a hotcake do you even know what
a hotcake is can i get an image of a hot
cake let's see if we can find an image
we can't get an image of a hot cake
curious what a hot cake is
it's like a hot pocket it's like an old
school hot pocket i guess
but yes we want to crush the new york
times best seller list just to expose
their nonsense so it's davereuben.com
book to pick up the book and of course i
am going on tour uh real quick we're
kicking this thing off in orlando
florida at the plaza live on april 18th
we're going to west palm clearwater
raleigh atlanta chicago dallas
washington dc uh west nyack new york
brea oxnard san jose phoenix and denver
real quick on the the dc show i'll have
some more information on this shortly
the original venue
that we had booked they had assured us
it was it was very important to me i was
not going to perform anywhere where
there were mask mandates vaccine
passports uh forced injections i just
was not going to be part of any of that
and suddenly the venue in dc switched it
up on us and they want people to have
passports or a negative cova test i'm
just not going to do it so we are
switching to another local theater i'll
have more info on that probably later
today or tomorrow if you've got tickets
don't worry don't do anything yet we
will communicate with you
and it will be an even better show
because now they've fired me up uh if
you haven't got tickets yet you can go
to daverman.com
events and uh that's all i got to say
about that so let's get into the show
joe biden is the guy pretending to be
president of the united states and he
welcomed former president of the united
states former two-time president of the
united states barack obama barack obama
who of course got less votes than the 81
million votes that old joe biden got
let's not forget that but he welcomed
him back to the white house for the
first time since uh leaving office
to do a little speech and talk in
celebration of obamacare even though
obamacare really kind of never worked
out a lot of it's been stripped away and
a lot of doctors hate it because of the
bureaucratic nonsense and the paperwork
and everything else
but it's a lot of pomp and circumstance
with these people uh and obama gave a
talk biden gave one of his muddling
things and then there were a couple
videos that came out after that i think
illustrate you know they say a picture
is worth a thousand worlds words well
video is worth a hell of a lot more than
that uh check out this video this was
right at the end of the reception see
where people are kind of going where the
energy is and what's happening on the
side of the energy
[Music]
so
[Music]
i feel bad for
jail i actually feel bad for joe i make
fun of joe biden all the time and i have
said many times i sympathize uh with
whatever's going on with him cognitively
obviously i've talked about it many
times
both of my grandmas had some uh form of
dementia later in their lives uh my
grandma elaine i spent a lot of time
with her going to geriatric doctors i
know what that is about
the forgetting the frustration the
confusion the missing words all of that
stuff the sort of doddering around i
mean it's obvious something's not right
with him
but let's put that aside for a second
in that room yesterday barack obama was
the president of the united states and
joe biden was not everyone was paying
attention to barack obama no one was
paying attention to bite i mean the
first video that we showed you in the
cold open that we also showed you right
there he's just fumbling around looking
for somebody to talk to like he's being
ignored and uh let's show the image the
still on this one this is really the
image of the whole thing there is joe
and look at look at his face like give
me attention look at me i'm president
man and obama's completely ignoring him
completely ignoring him and he's got his
hand on his shoulder like turn around
and in that video that's still from the
video that we just showed you there
obama is totally focused and smiled and
getting his ego stroked and everyone
loves barack
he knows that the president's touching
him you know
when someone's touching you you just
know it especially if it's the president
of the united states you know when
you're being grabbed it's not like a lot
of people are allowed to just walk up to
barack obama and grab him biden was also
yelling
to him at that point and he was ignoring
it and he was doing it intentionally
there's just no doubt about it there's
just
no doubt about it so we've got biden
first looking confused and being ignored
then you've got biden trying to get
obama's attention and obama just soaking
in the sunshine the love of the people
and
there are other leaders in the world and
they might be seeing videos like this
and what do you think that makes them
think
it probably makes them think a couple
things i would say at the very least it
makes them think boy
biden's pretty banged up and really not
up to the job it makes them also think
who's really
in charge here it makes them think what
is obama's move here
but it also probably makes them think
they can kind of do whatever they want
because this administration seems weak
now i want to contrast biden's fumbling
and stumbling with something from the
orange man a couple years ago this is
2017 at a meeting in europe and i'm sure
many of you will remember this
[Music]
okay so i'm not saying this is the most
important thing ever but i think it does
illustrate a problem that's in the world
that's related to everything you could
argue is going on in russia and ukraine
and everywhere else right now we have a
president that's that appears weak the
united states appears weak and confused
and muddled trump like him or not the
guy who burst through there he pushed
montenegro's prime minister out of the
way at a nato meeting gets up there does
the thing with the jacket you know he's
sort of like an ape he gets
beats his chest i'm trump
it's like whether you like that or not
whether that's disrespectful or not or
whatever it was it was asserting we are
the united states i walk out first
we can have all sorts of discussions
about how everyone should behave at nato
meetings and all of those things
but i'm just trying to show it to you
for the contrast of what is going on
from one administration to another but
the real reason i wanted to
show you this and discuss this was
because when i was watching the video of
obama yesterday and he's feeling
presidential again he's got the swagger
again and he knows like you you just
gotta know everybody in that room
whether they're an invited guest or a
staff member or literally the people
serving the hors d'oeuvres
everyone knows what's going on that the
biden thing is crumbling and falling
apart this has been a horrific disaster
of an administration the vp
is a is an abject disaster too like like
the whole thing is kind of coming coming
apart at the seams right
now
would barack obama be interested in a
third term i mean that seemed pretty
disrespectful didn't it to walk in there
and i'm the man
i'm gonna ignore you and i'm gonna be
shaking hands and smiling while you you
know you just kind of putter around old
dude uh but could we put it beyond
barack obama that actually he would like
to have a third term
i i i said this before i i uh
people would ask me
knowing what you know now do you wish
like you had a sec a third term
um
and i i used to say
you know what if if i could make an
arrangement where
um
i had a i had a stand in a front man
or front woman and they had an earpiece
in and i was just in my basement in my
sweats
looking through the
stuff and then i could sort of deliver
the lines but somebody else was
uh doing all the talking and ceremony
i'd be fine with that
oh
you'd be fine with that now look i know
he's being a little tongue-in-cheek but
he's also not he's saying yeah i would
love to continue being the most powerful
man in the world after my two terms are
over biden is obviously a puppet i'm not
saying he's absolutely a puppet
for barack obama i don't know that
barack obama is in the basement in
nantucket or in the new house in palm
springs right on the water despite
climate change or any of that
i don't know that he's
actually sitting there with the earpiece
say this joe say this joe i don't know
that but it does kind of feel like
barack is getting exactly what he wanted
doesn't it that this is what he wanted
if i could have a puppet in essence if i
could have some guy who would just do
all of the stuff that i want them to do
and we're having a continuation of that
and and by the way this isn't like some
crazy conspiracy theory i mean at the
beginning of the biden presidency they
were all talking about how they wanted
to you know continue
the obama legacy which was wiped away in
many ways by the trump presidency
um but
you know this is this is sort of what
joe wanted he brought in a lot of obama
people and you know he was vp
uh under obama and he loves obama i mean
even this back in 2007 i mean listen to
the great way that he talks about barack
obama i mean you got the first
sort of
mainstream african-american yeah
who was articulate and bright and
and clean and nice looking guys i mean
it's that's a storybook
ain't no racism like progressive lefty
racism is there yeah barack was the
first nice-looking articulate black guy
you know
thomas all
clarence thomas larry elder i'm not
going to just sit here and list black
people this is the most idiotic
offensive ridiculous thing but that is
the way they look at these ah there's
barack obama he's got nice teeth
he does have nice teeth
he must
be president of the united states for a
third term but all of this is making me
think that there's a lot going on here
and if if you just sit back and that's
why i've been trying to do the show the
way we're doing it lately with these
narrative stories if you just sit back
and you remember some of the things that
happened in the past
and you see what's happening in the
present you can actually kind of put the
story together and that then not feel so
crazy about everything so i want to link
this this obama
biden situation to what's going on with
elon musk at twitter because if obama's
getting back in in one way which to me
would be a negative way now elon musk is
making a move on twitter you all know
about this we've got some more info from
cnbc
elon musk and twitter have always been a
volatile combination that's especially
unlikely to change now with musk buying
a 9.2 stake in the social media company
and landing a seat on twitter's board of
directors for context twitter co-founder
and former ceo jack dorsey's stake in
twitter is just over two percent and
dorsey who stepped down as ceo in
november 2021 is leaving twitter's board
when his term ends in may
musk's board term will last until 2024.
oh that's sort of interesting doesn't
something big happen in 2024 the company
said in a separate regulatory filing
functionally making him a more powerful
figure within twitter than dorsey going
forward musk's piece of twitter is
technically categorized as a passive
stake which means it falls just below
the 10 threshold for a shareholder to be
considered an active or activist
shareholder typically passive
shareholders don't try to exert much
control over a company's decision making
musk might be the exception to that rule
so i want to focus on that part first so
he's right under this threshold which
sort of
uh de facto gives you more rights to
exert your control over the company you
exert your opinions et cetera et cetera
he's right below that but already
and actually even before he announced
the 9.2 percent we were talking about
this a week ago he was already exerting
influence over twitter just because he's
on twitter asking questions about
twitter and saying what's wrong with
this platform and are they defending
free speech
et cetera et cetera so now we've got a
series of tweets here from some of the
current players first up is twitter ceo
parag agrawal this is the guy who
replaced jack dorsey he said i'm excited
to share that we're appointing elon musk
to our board through conversations with
elon in recent weeks it became clear to
us that he would bring great value to
our board now that's of course nice to
hear
but he did not do anything this guy did
not do anything pro free speech or unban
anybody or anything like that in the
months since he took over from jack but
i suppose that's nice to hear he wants
to work with elon musk that's pretty
good now we've got something from ilan
himself looking forward to working with
peraga and the twitter board to make
significant improvements improvements to
twitter in coming months now okay that's
something because he's telling you hey i
got here for a reason
right i didn't just get this like
there's other things i can do with my
billions of dollars i'm here to actually
make a change well then former ceo jack
dorsey mr i'm constantly on a mushroom
trip he checked in and he said i'm
really happy elon is joining the twitter
board he cares deeply about our world
and twitter's role in it perag and elon
lead with their hearts and they will be
an incredible team
before i continue i want to just pause
for a second and say something because i
know a lot of you are not on twitter and
i actually think that's quite valuable
and enviable and good
you know there are plenty of people that
are not on twitter don't feel the need
to communicate on twitter and everything
else that being said these platforms
have become our public square at the
moment and they will not exist forever
that's one of the reasons why i'm always
against government regulation of them
because once the government comes and
regulates them it sort of calcifies them
into the system so these things won't
last forever better products will come
there is an alternate internet being
built which rumble and locals are part
of
but i think these these moments are
important because the the focus of the
conversation politically and culturally
is still on twitter twitter is still the
place for that so that people on say
youtube or rumble and other things or
people that are reporters or whatever
you want to call them journalists at cnn
or at the new york times they're still
reporting on what's going on on twitter
so that's why i think this is important
so if you're watching this and going
well i'm not on twitter i don't really
care about twitter it's like that still
is ground zero for
the conversation um so the washington
post
had an interesting take on this here's a
beautiful headline from the washington
post elon musk's twitter investment
could be bad news for free speech
it's literally the reverse of the truth
which is simply perfect for the
washington post elon made a point over
the course of the last few weeks of
saying i want to defend free speech i
don't like the way twitter is doing it i
am here
now putting my money where my mouth is
to ensure that they will be more
respectful of free speech principles but
of course washington post's
editorial about that was that it's going
to somehow
harm uh free speech but elon despite the
washington post the washington post
owned by jeff bezos by the way amazon's
jeff bezos the washington post sorry
here's some of the things that are
happening right now
going on on twitter related to free
speech well elon musk do you want an
edit button this is something people
have talked about for a long time
because you know occasionally you
actually mistype something or i find
iphone autocorrect is actually horrible
and doesn't warn me about words that are
mis-typed and sometimes confuses other
words and puts spaces between things and
all sorts of crazy stuff and you realize
it literally one second later
now the issue is if you were to add an
edit button do they have to acknowledge
that there was an edit what if it's
already got a thousand retweets there's
all sorts of stuff but this is something
that people have been clamoring about
literally for 10 years and then finally
one day later after elon musk says that
twitter communications now that
everyone's asking yes we've been working
on an edit feature since last year no we
didn't get the idea from a poll
we're kicking off testing within the
twitter blue labs in the coming months
to learn what works what doesn't and
what's possible now look again without
saying that twitter is the most
important thing in the world here
whether twitter has an edit button or
not is sort of secondary now we'll get
to the meat of this because the meat of
this is about free speech and our
ability to communicate with each other
not the government saying you can
communicate with each other but but
private citizens ability to communicate
with each other in the modern world and
elon musk is clearly trying to defend
that unless i am being completely duped
right now and everybody else is too that
seems to be what's going on here so
we've got some info from the daily wire
elon musk contacted the babylon b before
a substantial share of before buying a
substantial share of twitter according
to the christian satire's chief
executive musk is a fan of the babylon
bee which is currently suspended from
twitter for an article that jokingly
named health and human services
assistant secretary rachael and bean as
man of the year and was hosted on the
site's podcast at the end of last year
according to babylon b ceo seth dylan
the world's richest man consulted with
the babylon bee before purchasing a 9.2
stake in twitter musk reached out to us
before he polled his followers about
twitter's commitment to free speech
dylan reported he wanted to confirm that
we had in fact been suspended he even
used on a call that he might need to buy
twitter now he's the largest shareholder
and has a seat on the board twitter has
thus far refused to revoke its decision
to lock the babylon bees account
according to dylan the company wrote our
support team has determined that a
violation did take place and therefore
we will not overturn the decision now
there's a couple interesting things here
so the babylon bee is suspended for
quite literally making a joke
quite literally making a joke now we
know that the ayatollah
is on twitter we know that hamas is on
twitter we know that terror
organizations like antifa are on twitter
or blacklivesmatter is on twitter and
there's all sorts of bad people that say
horrible things on twitter
in my estimation as long as you're not
breaking the laws of the united states
you should be allowed to be on twitter
and people can block you or mute you or
whatever it might be but the babylon bee
is suspended because of a joke and then
even though still very few people are
talking about this it's important to
note that tucker carlson the number one
rated host in the history of cable news
is suspended right now for the exact
same thing for basically saying rachel
levine is a man not a woman a biological
man not a woman that is a fact that is
an uncomfortable fact but that is a fact
so elon musk is defending the bee i
suspect that the babylon b will be back
on there soon which also leads us
perhaps to believe that a certain orange
man might be back on there we've got
some info here from the washington
examiner because they went in and they
said well who is it maybe that's been
gone from twitter that elon musk could
bring back in i'll just give you a
couple of them here you've got roger
stone conservative political consultant
and lobbyist alex jones you all know who
he is
then there's of course the orange man
himself
former president donald trump
you've got republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor green she's a current
congresswoman who is now suspended on
twitter you've got james o'keefe from
project veritas you've got dr robert
malone who has more patents on mrna
technology than anyone if i'm not
mistaken he is suspended and there's
plenty of other people that are
suspended and as you know i've been
suspended for different things these
people are at the moment per
are fully banned i've been temporarily
suspended um so the question really is
there's a couple questions here so first
off what is elon going to do he didn't
just buy this nine percent stake and
then put himself on the board or ask to
be put on the board to not solve some of
these issues he had to know these issues
were coming he had to know that the
first thing that was going to happen to
him was they were all going to say what
are you going to do about trump what are
you going to do about trump right that's
it that's the big one but it's not just
that it's not just those people james
o'keefe and marjorie taylor green and
whoever else regardless of your feelings
about these people it's not just about
those people specifically there's also
this other issue
there's this hunter biden laptop issue
that someone at twitter or a team of
people
at twitter decided to make sure that
they were not going to allow this story
to be put up but it also goes beyond
that uh phoenix we can go back to this
part this uh this donald trump situation
because remember what twitter said when
donald trump was suspended we've got the
actual quotes from twitter themselves
this is when donald trump was suspended
they said after close review of recent
tweets from the real donald trump
account and the context around them
specifically how they are being received
and interpreted on and off twitter we
have permanently suspended the account
due to risk of further incitement or
balance don't go forward yet actually
connor can you go back for just a second
i want to go back to that that text
there there's something really
interesting here because what they're
saying is they're not really saying this
is after january 6 that donald trump
incited violence on twitter because we
know that he didn't do that he didn't
call for violence he didn't say storm
the capital he didn't say bring weapons
anything like that right you may not
have liked some of his language but we
know he did not do that what they're
saying there is the language around it
how it's been received and interpreted
that's very dangerous because anything
that any of us say can be received and
interpreted very differently than we
mean it right i can only be held account
for my words i can't be a held account
for how you interpret my words and what
you might do after now if i was
literally up here screaming for a
violent act to take place against a
specific person or a specific building
then we've got something but it's a very
dangerous place when we say that the the
move around language the force field
around language isn't just the words
themselves but it's how people receive
those words that words that's a very
different thing let's continue on that
in the this is how twitter framed it in
the context of horrific events this week
we made it clear on wednesday that
additional violations of the twitter
rules would potentially result in this
very course of action our public
interest framework exists to enable the
public to hear from elected officials
and world leaders directly it is built
upon a principle that the people have a
right to hold power to account in the
open now of course this is complete
nonsense so let me sorry i'll finish up
and then i'll analyze i'm getting ahead
to the anal analyzation first however we
made it clear going back years that
these accounts are not above our rules
entirely and cannot use twitter to
incite violence among other things we
will continue to be transparent around
our policies and their enforcement okay
so first off they're not transparent
about their policies or their
enforcement we all know about shadow
bannings we know that they always ban
and suspend people that are on the right
far more than they do on people on the
left we know that the government of
china which is no
bastion of free speech is on twitter i
mentioned the ayatollah before i
mentioned hamas i mean we know that
these things are on there so they have
different policies depending on sort of
who they're in bed with and perhaps who
their investors are and whatever else it
might be
and then when you throw in this hunter
biden story that
quite literally might have changed the
course of the election right it quite
literally might have changed the course
of the election
and now jack dorsey believe it or not
now that jack dorsey is out and he's
only got his two percent and he's not
ceo of twitter anymore he's basically
saying that the uh
the hunter biden story well that was and
how it happened to twitter and the whole
thing that it was pretty much a mistake
we've got some info here from the new
york post
twitter doesn't have a censoring
department that blocked the post from
tweeting last fall ceo jack
dorsey said on thursday but he wouldn't
reveal who was responsible for the
blunder at a congressional hearing on
misinformation and social media dorsey
said twitter made a total mistake by
barring users from sharing the post
bombshell october report about hunter
biden's emails twitter also locked the
post out of its account for more than
two weeks over baseless charges that the
expose used hacked information a
decision dorsey chalked up to a process
error
it was literally just a process error
there was this was not against them in
any particular way dorsey told the house
energy and commerce committee
if we remove a violation we require
people to correct it he added we change
that based on there to wanting to delete
that tweet which i completely agree with
i see it but is something it is
something we learn twitter demanded that
the post delete six tweets that link to
stories based on files from the
abandoned laptop of president biden's
son
of president president biden's son
twitter backed down after the paper
refused to remove the posts a
development the post celebrated on its
october 31st front page with the
headline free
bird okay so let's be very clear
that was jack dorsey saying those things
under oath to a committee a
congressional committee and he's
obviously lying what does that mean it's
a processing error we didn't know what
we were doing we had no idea there was
no political pressure brought to bear
who did it why is there no why did
nobody get fired about this why are
there is there nobody oh you know there
were a couple meetings like there are
emails about this stuff this is
important stuff even if you don't think
twitter's that important
the idea that a major media company
censored a story that we all know now is
true two weeks ago finally the new york
times confirmed that it is true the 51
former intelligence people who all said
it was russian misinformation they had
no evidence of that they all made it up
none of them are being hauled in front
of congress either there's there's so
much smoke here there's so much smoke
but we have to figure out where the fire
is and i suspect maybe elon musk is
going to find the fire maybe because now
he is going to have the ability to get
access to who had meetings with who
about what they were going to do was
this what does that mean it was a
processing error there was some sort of
coding problem and for some reason
people couldn't dm the story from the
new york post oh and the story it was
just the one time we had this processing
error and it just had it was just right
before the election and it just happened
to help the guy we want and hurt the guy
we don't want it's a freaking
coincidence like you wouldn't believe
get it guys you get it you can put some
of this stuff together you can put these
pieces together i think this can get joe
biden in serious trouble i think maybe
barack obama knows it why which is why
he's suddenly back in the fold who
freaking knows who knows
who knows
uh peter ducey you guys know peter ducey
over at fox news he's an actual
journalist it's so refreshing not to
have to stretch my fingers and do this
when i say journalist around fox news is
peter ducey well he asked
jen saki yesterday if they would support
an independent special counsel
because now the hunter biden laptop
thing even though it was just a
processing error on the part of twitter
yeah it turned out to be real a lot of
stories about hunter biden servicing
this week so to ensure the independence
of the investigation would the president
support the appointment of a special
counsel well first the president has
never had a conversation with the
department of justice about any
investigations into any member of his
family he said that during the campaign
and he will continue to abide by that so
i'd point to the department of justice
for any additional steps they would take
they would make those decisions
independently is there any concern that
they're not going to be
necessarily seen as being able to make
the decisions independently if the white
house chief of staff is out saying
that
the president is confident his son did
not break the law
well that's something the president has
said and certainly we would echo but in
the same answer to that question peter
during an interview this week on abc ron
clayne also said the justice department
is independent and they will make their
own decisions
i don't think it's overstating it to say
that this could take down the
administration something is going on
here
a major
big tech media company censored a story
that we all know is now true this the
stuff that's on the laptop the emails
and why hunter biden was involved with
ukrainian energy companies and whether
money was going up to the big guy
meaning biden on top of whatever else he
was doing smoke and crack in the
pictures and all of that stuff
this is bad this is bad and if it is
being referred to the justice department
which is what saki's saying it's kind of
funny that saki's quitting her job at
the same time right we talked about that
yesterday saki's going over to msnbc
she's going to continue to be a paid
liar but she's just not going to do it
for the administration anymore she's
going to do it over on msnbc so she kind
of sees the writing on the wall and
something seems a little fishy about all
of this
ducey continued to ask sake some stuff
and the president has said that he never
spoke to his son about his overseas
business dealings is that still the case
yes
good
that's pretty uh straightforward there
saki you're saying yes but it never
spoke to his son about his business
healings think about how nonsensical
this is really think about this for a
second
hunter biden has no experience doing
anything in the energy sector he was a
crack addict artist
he was then getting paid
millions of dollars
by an energy company in ukraine why was
he getting paid that money if they
wanted to find a crack addict uh artist
they could have gone to the streets of
seattle and picked up anybody but they
picked up the vice president's son do
you think it possibly was because i know
this is this alex jones level stuff but
do you think it's possible that a
ukrainian energy company that wants
certain things done they want certain
deals passed they want certain people in
certain positions right
um do you think they might be like hey
could we pay the president's crack
addict son who has no experience doing
anything so we'll give him a whole bunch
of money
so that maybe
he will have some ability to get his dad
to do something what jensaki just said
right there first off they're saying
that's all just not true no he actually
was qualified for the job just not true
but what gen saki said there is no biden
has never had a conversation about that
with his son so he's ne so joe biden and
hunter biden have never talked about
hunter biden's work that's pretty crazy
uh any of you that are out there that
have fathers or any of you are that are
out there that are fathers is there
literally any person on earth that has
never talked to their father or their
son about what they do for a living but
apparently that's what's happened with
the old confused guy and the crack
addict
i should write a children's book the old
confused guy and the crack addict that's
going to be my next children's book uh
anyway this thing stinks this thing
stinks to high hell and uh i don't know
i'm not a private investigator i'm just
not an idiot so that's why i'm talking
about it i don't think you're going to
get that on cnn
um
and in summation
now the obama thing it all feels like
something it all feels like something
and that's all i got to say about that
let's get some comments from the locals
community uh cat says hope your kids
grow up under a desantis presidency
look
my feelings are clear on this i want
desantis to crush it and i i think he
will crush it and i think it could be
like record level crushing it in florida
i think he could win this thing 60
i think it'd be 62 i mean i think he
will absolutely crush it here
in florida i mentioned the other day
that when desantis came in i'm going to
get these numbers slightly off but it's
close to this when desantis came in
there were more democrats than
republicans in florida by something like
250 000 i think it's about 80 000 more
republicans than democrats right now i'm
pretty close on those numbers so just
that alone
on top of the fact that all these people
are moving here and know why they're
moving here and all the good reasons
that we talk about florida all the time
so look i want desantis to crush it and
then then he'll have another two years
to keep florida strong model that
hopefully get some other
uh governors in other states to have
some balls fight for what they believe
in you know institute some of the
policies here in free florida and then
and then there has to be a discussion
well the discussion actually has to
happen probably early 2023 so not that
long from now the discussion has to
happen you know in about 10 months
are you going to consider
doing the presidential thing the real
question again is where does trump fall
on that i think desantis overall
obviously would be a better candidate
but i'm more concerned about my state
than i am about the presidency right now
that and that's the way the country was
set up so it's okay uh but yes obviously
i would support desantis for president
margot says maybe biden will get mad
enough that he calls up the orange guy
and says go get him
yeah exactly remember that remember go
get him uh at the end of uh that speech
he gave a couple weeks ago you remember
that big speech he gave and then he just
yelled out of nowhere go get him and
it's like who what where when why
current events what's going on here
adam says musk just pulled a bruce wayne
level power move yeah it is one of those
moves like right out of a movie right
it's right out of bruce wayne walking
into the boardroom and like you're all
fired or just any any movie about
business when there's that moment in the
boardroom um i think i think you're
you're totally right this is a this is a
power move by a guy
that can make power moves and you know
you see a lot of people i think i've
said this once or twice before um
you see a lot of people that say oh you
know these people that have fu money if
i had fu money right if i had all this
money in the world then i'd say what i
want because i wouldn't be worried about
anything i would just do what i want say
what i want i'd fight for all the right
things and everything else
it's simply not the case it's simply not
the case i think what often happens and
there are some notable exceptions to
this and i i you know i i know some
people in in these categories through
the show and some friendships there are
some notable exceptions of to this so
i'm not i'm not condemning everyone but
one of the things that happens and it's
just human nature by the way you start
getting more money now you have more
employees let's say more people that are
dependent on you
all sorts of other things that happen
and then suddenly you actually become
less willing to risk it because you now
feel the weight of those other people
and those employees and all of those
things and the stuff that you got
and then more people actually become
quiet so in many ways uh the less that
you have to lose the more that you will
fight right like i mean watch the movie
rocky it's like when was he was at his
best in the in the early years when he
had nothing right he was this this
fighter out of bro out of philly and he
had absolutely nothing and then rocky
iii remember rocky iii when uh what's
his name mr t is involved and mr t is
hungry and rocky is doing commercials
and he's got money and endorsements and
mr t is kicking the crap out of him why
because he's not as hungry so that is
one of those things so the fact that
elon musk still puts himself in these
positions i mean this is a guy who could
live in ways that that truly you cannot
imagine
that i cannot imagine there are pro the
access to money and his ability to
freaking go to space and if he wanted to
live on mars he could figure out a way
to do it like
it's it's off the charts
the difference between the way he can
live and the way pretty much everyone
else on earth can live
and instead of just focusing on all of
the things that are his intellectual
pursuits and his pursuit of other
literally other worlds he's saying hey
i'll fix a problem here
that's a pretty good guy
that's a pretty good guy guys reminder
in six days don't burn this country
comes out you can get your copy now
please do get it if you have not you can
get it in old school book form or you
can get it in audiobook form however you
like it dave rubin.com
book and all the links to the different
vendors are there and of course you can
join me on tour
where a whole bunch of great people are
going to be joining me don jr and megan
kelly and larry elder and dennis prager
and blake masters and michael malus and
janmi park and brian callan and benny
johnson and who did i forget uh who
don junior i think i said that one and
anyone else that we want to repeat that
i said already i'll just say one that i
said already megan kelly it's going to
be great people
daverubin.com events and if you want to
play along for the live chat during the
show check out reubenreport.locals.com
and i think you'll enjoy
our cold clothes for today see you
tomorrow
[Applause]
you